when someone wants to communicate an
update on a project or any other
initiative or train of thought that
they're having it would often go like
this
so yeah this is what I think and this is
because of this reason and then there's
also this other reason and I are there's
other reason to support this way so
don't do that don't communicate like
this this will be perceived as a very
unstructured instead leverage the rule
of three but the basic idea is that you
should start Always by saying something
like this is what I hold true and it's
because of three reasons so you always
start by saying there are three reasons
for something first second and third